Ladies and gentlemen,
my guy, Mr. Ray Grady.
Here we are.
Otherwise known as Grady.
Yeah, yeah, Grady.
KEVIN HART: Grady right now.
How long, man?
How long you at-- how long
you been at comedy now?
15 years.
15 years, man.
Where you from, Grady?
Tell the people where you from.
Chicago, born and raised.
KEVIN HART: Cha town.
You feel like right now you
putting on for you city?
Yeah, why not?
Because it's a lot of negativity
around with the term Chiraq.
Most people from Chicago,
we don't claim that.
That's the media.
So we like, nah, we just regular
blue collar people like Philly,
Baltimore, Detroit, Oakland.
Definitely just named four
of the most murdering cities
in the-- in the United States.
That was a segue!
That was right there.
See, comics, you can
alley-oops one another.
That was a dime.
That was like,
yeah, we don't go
by that name, four of the most
murdering cities in the US.
Was it love at first sight
when you first got on stage?
[bleep] No.
No, no.
That's a genuine
laugh right there.
That's all I wanted
to see, I was waiting.
Why-- why not?
Tell me why not.
Well I mean, because you--
you can be funny around
your friends, your family,
but they all liars.
KEVIN HART: OK.
They gonna tell you
what you wanna hear.
I don't know none
of these people
here except for the six
dudes in here, right?
They laughing.
That's when know you
can-- know what I mean?
So it took me a while, you
know, I kept going back,
kept bombing, kept bombing.
Bombing, wow.
Staying persistent to it,
never doubted yourself.
Well, I can fight, so that
cut a lot of [bleep] out.
Boo me, I'm
gonna wait for you.
That's great.
No, no, but it was just,
I wasn't afraid to lose.
You know what I mean?
So if you going
to be successful--
That's big!
That's a big-- that's actually
a very powerful statement, man.
Because I think in
stand up comedy,
you have to have that mindset.
A lot of people step on
the stage and, you know,
are afraid to fail, or afraid
to not hear those laughs.
RAY GRADY: Yeah, because
they not-- it's not personal.
They don't know me.
- Yeah.
But I got the power.
KEVIN HART: OK
Because my voice
is a man's voice.
When I speak--
I think there's
another shot at me.
I think that's another--
that's another shot.
No, Kev, I'm just--
know what I mean?
I will definitely say
Grady does have probably one
of the best voices in comedy.
Alpha male, baby.
Gotta be a alpha male
if you hang with me.
You know when you
keep saying that, I feel
like you saying that I'm not--
that I'm not where I'm
supposed to be as a male.
Hey, y'all make some
noise for my guy,
Grady, it's time to walk
into the next level, baby.
Gotta go to work.